alright everybody let's get to my first
guest she is not only a beautiful singer
but also a beautiful person we have
watched her grow up from a disney
channel started to the strong woman she
is today
she's had nine top 20 songs and has been
named one of times most influential
people super cool you can see her
starting tomorrow flexing her acting
skills once again and Eurovision Song
Contest the story of fire saga on
Netflix it's an amazing film it's
awesome she's the one and only
Demi Lovato hey what's up Jimmy can you
hear me yeah I can hear you
oh good how are you doing good how are
you I'm doing all right
I what have you been doing in quarantine
everybody's got a kind of a different
thing going on mine has been filled with
kids and trying to entertain them like a
clown what does your life like mine is
taking care of my dogs my fur babies so
they're my kids
and yeah just spending a ton of time
with them I I actually picked up some
like good habits and quarantine which
for like Oh journaling I never used to
journal before and I picked up
journaling I picked up yoga which I
always hated until now and it's what it
did and it was a perfect medicine for
perfect turn in my life and I'm I
couldn't be more grateful no I I agree
I'm I've been having the same thing and
I'm I actually love I'm jumping had the
interview but it's just kind of a nice
segue I love how open you are about
mental health because I have similar
issues and I have suffered from
depression I've I think a lot of people
especially in the creative world or just
from childhood you've been kind of
trained to like just keep going and you
can handle it and especially as a woman
it's like don't let them see you sweat
like it's you know so it's it's I just
love that you're open about that because
not everybody's as vulnerable at being
like that and I think it's helpful for
your fans and because I know and every
meet-and-greet you probably get people
saying that I do too and they're like
man thank you for just like being open
and your songs and open you know with
everybody cuz I felt like this was just
me and like knowing that somebody else
is going through it makes you not feel
alone and so depressed about it so thank
you for doing that it's really hard
I just have
say that you were like the first Idol
that I ever had and so sweet I wouldn't
be the artist or even the person that I
am with being so outspoken and
vulnerable and fearless if I hadn't had
you to look up to so I think you for
that he can be nice yes I just like I
looked at you as my idol growing up um
you you are fearless and courageous and
real as you know and you and I love that
about you and I've always just thought
to myself like when I was young I always
talk to myself if I ever make it I want
to be like her because she's brutal and
she's genuine and I think the thing
about it though is even you're saying
like you know you're strong you're
courageous you're all those things I'm
not all the time I takes work like it's
like that's the thing I think everybody
looks at us is like like even when you
overcome something they're like okay so
she's already ever come they're like no
no that's a daily effort and like trying
to be positive that's a daily effort and
and that's not like a given like you're
just over it and you went to some
magical therapy session and it's over I
think that's a daily thing that you work
at and a daily thing that I work at and
I I don't know I hear the compliments
but I just think it's really it's a
really cool thing and it's not easy to
always have a spotlight on you and
arrows being aimed at you especially
when you are vulnerable and you give
people more ammo for all the trolls out
there so anyway but think thank you for
doing that I love and I don't even know
if you saw me tweeted by Damon so hard
to your new single I love it I think
it's such a it's like refreshing
whenever you hear a song - and you
haven't heard it saying like that you
haven't heard the message kind of
twisted like that and I was like whoa I
was like that was a really powerful
message but cleverly done and I'm
telling you what Jedi level sabotage is
[ __ ] my favorite lyric I've heard in a
very long time spired this song is it
just your life and kind of just really
daily kind of figuring out you and yes
so I actually wrote that song last
summer
recorded it last summer and I did it
with my producer oak Felder who I did
sorry sorry with a bunch of other songs
I loved Oh Keith great yes he's so great
and he's you know he's obsessed with
Star Wars so you know Star Wars
memorabilia in his studio and he came up
with that lyric and I was like oh that's
genius we got to put that in there but
yeah I just like the message I felt like
I wasn't being authentic
to people because I've been editing
pictures like I had gone on a vacation
to Bora Bora last year and I did the
bikini pictures and I posted them and I
got a bunch likes but it didn't feel
good because I was putting up something
that wasn't real I felt like I was
catfishing everybody and but you
probably felt the need to do that
because everybody does that and like if
you do come out looking real yes it's
like people don't even know what that's
supposed to look like anymore yes it's
like teenagers I would be I wouldn't be
surprised if they didn't know what
cellulite or stretch to stretch marks
stretch marks look like until they pop
up on their body and then all of a
sudden they have to face tuning out of
their pictures because I'm doing it and
they see me doing so I was like no I
need to change this I need to change the
narrative I need to like post something
real and so I posted something while I
was like in the studio and it was that
unedited bikini picture and it just felt
so good because I had a few crushes at
the time and it was interesting to see
that all of those crushes they actually
likes that picture where all my
cellulite was out and yeah I wasn't
touched up and I was like oh my gosh
like here's these people I was trying to
impress they were the ones I was trying
to impress not people like fans or
anything I know that they accept me and
love me for me but I was trying to you
know look hot for my crap and then at
some point it's like well they're gonna
see you eventually like me and I don't
want them to like think I'm catfishing
them so yeah you know I
anyways I fell that was like the first
step in kind of owning taking the power
back from what other people were placed
the judgments people are placing on my
body I got to take the power back and be
like okay you really want to judge me
here it is yeah nothing that you say is
going to affect what the strength and
the love that I have of myself up here
so come out clean I feel like it's
really freeing because I've we're both
women in an industry that is hard on
women and harder on women
all right so Timmy you've been very
vocal which I appreciate because we have
gigantic platforms that I think we
should use but you've been pretty vocal
about black lives matters so what do you
think personally that we can all do
differently I think the first step is
educating ourselves we have a lot of
time on our hands right now
there is no reason why we shouldn't be
watching these movies watching an
absorbing and all information that we
possibly can about what's going on in
the world and then from there you know
we've we've seen it all over the media
that that being silent and being not
racist is not enough anymore and that's
kind of something that I posted I posted
about like a month ago when the Amato
bery stuff happened I was like I felt I
would I saw online what had happened and
I felt this overwhelming sense of like
frustration anger I was like crying and
I started writing in my phone I just got
out all my emotions and I felt guilty
that I hadn't been doing more and saying
more as an ally but I was also afraid
that people were going to come at me
because they will yes because
everybody's angry right now and I just I
didn't want anyone to think that I had
the wrong intentions or that I was
uneducated you know like speaking about
something that I didn't know about that
it was a fear of mine and so I kind of
when that happened I and even before or
before I found out about George Floyd I
was like no I need to do more I need to
be an ally I have not been an ally I
have like Aretha Franklin Billie Holiday
Whitney Houston these women of color
have like shaped my
musical journey and how am I supposed to
appreciate what they've given me and not
stand up for their community and so I
just I switched my thinking and then all
of this happen and you know I wish I had
kind of come to that realization sooner
but I think everything happens in its
own timing and I've gotten to a place
where like because I'm able to deal with
my own demons my own things I can now
kind of help um
advocate for other people and I think
maybe that's a reason why some people
aren't speaking out and doing things is
they're afraid but they're also like not
ready to help other people um I don't
know I just wanted to be the ally that I
know I can be and I want to be able to
shift thinking as much as possible
because my the legacy that I will leave
as a person will last so much longer
than the music that we leave behind yeah
totally your character means everything
I agree subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel please
don't make me keep going